[Música]
[Aplausos]
Bienvenidos a corresponsales el programa
que los lleva a dar una vuelta al mundo
de la mano de nuestra red de periodistas
soy arminia Fernández desde el comienzo
de la invasión voluntario de toda
Ucrania se han movilizado para ayudar a
militares y a los civiles necesitados
pero ninguno tiene una historia como
ésta la de un hombre de maripol que
ayudó a evacuar a cientos de civiles en
las condiciones más peligrosas y no se
detuvo ahí desde entonces su creciente
equipo de voluntarios recorren los
peores epicentros de las zonas de
conflicto France 24 se reunió con él
entre las ruinas del sur de Ucrania
no están en tanques ni en trincheras
pero este grupo de 15 hombres y mujeres
pasan sus días y noches en las zonas más
castigadas del frente ucraniano mijaílo
y su grupo de voluntarios son jóvenes y
optimistas como milana que tiene 19 años
me gusta formar parte de este equipo a
pesar de todos los bombardeos los
últimos cracks cayeron allí y allí hace
dos días yo misma limpié los escombros
daba un poco de miedo
el equipo ha estado montando un refugio
en Julia Pole una ciudad devastada de la
región de saporilla arrasada por los
obuses Y las bombas rusas unas 2000
personas siguen viviendo aquí pero
aisladas de los servicios básicos para
otras personas esto puede parecer
rutinario pero para mí es un milagro es
el único Grifo que funciona en todo cuya
Pole
y eso no es todo comida electricidad de
un generador
incluso lavadoras Esto es lo que en
Ucrania se conoce como un punto de
invencibilidad un lugar donde aferrarse
para sobrevivir quieres ducharte
mijailo es de maripol donde dirigía una
empresa de software en línea y un club
nocturno en los primeros días de la
invasión evacuó a sus cuatro hijos y
luego regresó
volvía Mario por el 7 de marzo para
cuidar de mis empleados pero cuando
llegué al club nocturno había 200
personas refugiadas en el sótano empecé
a evacuarlas de la ciudad y así fue como
empecé a trabajar como voluntario cuando
resultó imposible realizar nuevas
evacuaciones mijailo acudió en ayuda de
las personas atrapadas en otras ciudades
sitiadas
como adifka y
si quieres evacuar puedo conseguirte una
casa es un sitio muy bonito los dueños
te dejarán todo el lugar
ahora su tarea en cuya Pole está
terminada los voluntarios montaron este
centro en una semana ser voluntario es
otra forma de luchar algunas personas
han ido a Europa y luchan enviando
dinero otras son activas en las redes
sociales comentando y retuiteando cada
uno está en su primera línea luchando a
su manera a los jóvenes les inspira a
formar parte de algo y dejar una pequeña
huella en la historia y la victoria
gracias a las donaciones mijailo y su
equipo se dirigen ahora a la próxima
ciudad ucraniana necesitada
los refugiados sirios son tema de las
elecciones en Turquía país que acoge
oficialmente a casi 4 millones de estos
migrantes con los refugiados de por
medio el debate de la segunda vuelta
está girando en torno a este tema
informe de ludovic de foucault use y
jonatha chariya
en el sur de Turquía aquí uno de cada
cuatro habitantes es sirio y ya no son
bienvenidos el pueblo Turco quiere que
los indios se vayan ya los hemos acogido
bastante ahora el 95% de los turcos
quieren que los sirios se vayan de Cara
a la segunda vuelta de las elecciones
presidenciales turcas el discurso de la
oposición se endurece contra los
extranjeros a los que ahora acusan de
Invasores delincuentes y violadores en
potencia pero este líder local del
partido republicano del pueblo quiere
mostrarse amable frente a la prensa
extranjera
primero debemos asegurarnos de que Siria
esté en paz y de que nuestros amigos
sirios puedan regresar de forma segura y
voluntaria
pero la estrategia está Clara aglutinar
a la extrema derecha ultranacionalista y
sus cinco por ciento de los votos a
pesar de su campaña sobre el miedo a un
gran reemplazo social
nosotros tenemos una media de dos hijos
por familia Pero los sirios tienen una
media de seis hijos no es natural a ese
ritmo en 10 años controlarán todas las
administraciones de gaseantep cómo puede
aceptar esto nuestro pueblo estos
refugiados deben marcharse el año que
viene Esta es la primera y más
importante condición un discurso que
trivializa los actos de odio y racismo
en Turquía desde el comienzo de esta
campaña los sirios han mantenido un bajo
perfil en la ciudad Siria de dair el sur
el doctor munir era un médico respetado
antes de ser encarcelado y torturado por
el régimen aquí no es más que otro
extranjero que teme ser devuelto a sus
torturadores
psicológicamente es muy difícil para los
sirios en Turquía en este momento veo
televisión y tengo la impresión de
seguir la campaña incluso más que los
turcos no podemos acudir a la policía
primero para no causar problemas y
segundo porque sabemos que nadie nos
defiende bajo estas condiciones qué cree
que va a pasar si la oposición llega al
poder
toda la clase política siente esta
presión xenófoba el ministro del
interior asegura que los sirios son
hermanos pero que Turquía nunca se
convertirá en un depósito de refugiados
en Colombia sigue la búsqueda de cuatro
niños desaparecidos tras el accidente de
una avioneta en la selva en la que
murieron tres adultos a las fuerzas
armadas se unieron distintas comunidades
indígenas conocedoras del territorio
ante la falta de nuevas informaciones
las autoridades brindan confianza a los
saberes ancestrales nuestros enviados
especiales a la zona lluís Muñoz y aitor
chavarri tienen el informe
Harvey Gómez ha estado más de dos
semanas en la selva su misión encontrar
a cuatro niños perdidos tras un
accidente de avioneta en el que murieron
tres adultos igual que Harvey eran
indígenas huitotos y upodes uno de los
adultos era su tío Germán Mendoza un
líder social Harvey encontró la avioneta
no pidiéndole a la madre naturaleza pues
ella le ayuda los indígenas están siendo
clave en la búsqueda de los niños como
Leandro Ibáñez de la comunidad siona es
uno de los 25 guardias procedentes de
las comunidades amazónicas de caqueta y
putumayo han llegado a San José del
guaviare el centro de la operación
esperanza de rescate lo hacen Para
apoyar a las fuerzas armadas en la
búsqueda de los abuelos ancestrales que
nos guían y no abran ese espacio para
nosotros poder llegar al territorio y
encontrar aquellos niños que están
desaparecidos esta unión entre y
organizaciones indígenas es inédita
responde al pedido del primer gobierno
de izquierda de la historia de Colombia
los militares comparten información
mapas y los avances de la operación
después Leandro sube un bus que los
conducirá a la base aérea que les
llevará a una selva rodeada de misterios
pero que conocen bien
esperan encontrarlos un orgullo Sería
para todo Colombia y los pueblos
indígenas tras más de 20 días de
búsqueda los militares reconocen las
informaciones ancestrales para el
hallazgo de huellas y Rastros de los
niños el objetivo de indígenas y
uniformados es común buscarlos hasta
encontrarlos
monumentos del centro histórico de Roma
asaltado por el turismo de massa la
capital italiana tiene un lado
desconocido en donde los protagonistas
son espectaculares murales pintados en
edificios anónimos en los barrios
periféricos una forma de arte urbano que
en los últimos años ha dado una nueva
vida a las zonas populares generando
inclusive el interés de un nuevo tipo de
turismo en la capital italiana nuestra
corresponsal en Italia Natalia Mendoza
nos cuenta más
varios tarros de pintura unos pinceles y
un fular para cubrir su cara Esto es lo
único que necesita Carlos satoche para
dar rienda suelta a su imaginación este
artista urbano de origen peruano pinta
exclusivamente en incógnito
hace años decidí mantener mi entidad
oculta en una voluntad de querer que la
gente te identifique más con tus obras
que con tu cara no desde hace más de
diez años Carlos pinta murales
callejeros en países como Marruecos
china Perú y Vietnam esta mañana su
Lienzo es esta fachada de este edificio
abandonado en el sur de Roma este
diálogo que hay entre la obra y
el marco arquitectónico Pues es lo que
lo hace un arte única digamos no pintar
en la calle es sin filtros es mucho más
directo la streettar es un arte que se
expande por sí sola no es un organismo
vivo una forma de expresión cada vez más
visible en Roma que inicia a interesar
al mundo del turismo estos visitantes
participan a un toura típico en un
barrio de la periferia transformado en
museo a cielo abierto
Esta obra representa a los bombardeos en
Roma de 1943 durante la Segunda Guerra
Mundial pero también Las Guerras en el
mundo que desafortunadamente siguen
ocurriendo hoy en día
es muy importante porque en general uno
viene a Roma y ve siempre las mismas
cosas Iglesias El Vaticano y arte
tradicional Y entonces es excelente
poder descubrir esto que es tan
diferente e inusual
obras que denuncian la pobreza la
violencia de género o Inclusive la
contaminación ambiental como esta
gigantesca imagen de una garza sobre un
barril de petróleo se trata del mural
ecológico más grande de Europa
para este mural se usaron pinturas
fotocatalíticas es decir que reaccionan
al contacto con la luz atacan las
partículas de polución y las disuelven
este mural absor be la polución generada
por 80 carros al día
actualmente unos 330 murales de interés
artístico decoran la ciudad de Roma
hasta aquí corresponsales de la semana
nuestro agradecimiento a Juan barista de
coffee Shop por habernos cedido sus
instalaciones para grabar Este programa
siga con más información por trans 24 y
Francia 24.com